okay so this guy the billionaire stepson
posted Hamish my stepdad is lost in a
submarine thoughts and prayers that the
rescue mission will be successful and
then the next day
he posts a picture of himself at a Blink
182 concert it might be distasteful of
being here but my family would want me
to be at the Blink 182 show it's my
favorite band and music helps me in
difficult times he then even tweeted at
them
basically saying like my stepdad is lost
in the submarine no way actually I hope
this is a good one
damn yeah
dark yep where are you
yeah oh God damn Ryan damn dude damn I
go to Europe for four weeks I come back
Ryan's funny holy